welcome to this special edition of
hannity i'm dan bongino
and tonight for sean now joe biden and
the extreme democrats tonight are
failing at the border
failing abroad and failing to deliver
for working-class americans all across
this great country
and the worst part is they're doubling
down on this reckless radical ridiculous
irresponsible
socialist agenda every single chance
they get
for example joe biden's unveiling a
whopping six trillion dollar budget
proposal the largest in us history that
would vastly expand the size and scope
of the already bloated in debt federal
government and vastly increase
washington's role
in managing your everyday life according
to estimates if actually enacted
the plan would put the annual budget
deficit at 1.3
trillion per year for the next decade
and would put us on a path to having the
highest international debt as a
proportion of the economy
so don't be fooled by the democrats
political platitudes
their cheap nonsense talking points and
their far-left fantasies
what joe biden is doing is mortgaging
our future and your kids too
and creating a perfect storm for fiscal
chaos for current
and future generations what joe biden
was doing right now it's not smart it's
not even insane
and it's certainly not sustainable it's
a big government binge
more taxes more debt more spending and
guaranteed turmoil
don't buy the democrats lies that these
trillions and trillions will be paid by
the so-called
rich do the math it's common sense
because in the end this will be paid for
by you working class dirt under the
fingernails middle class americans
work for a living all across the country
and what about inflation
rising costs at the gas pump at your
grocery store
you're going to have to pay for that too
but the destructive democratic agenda
doesn't stop there
because despite an intensifying crisis
at our southern border biden's budget
leaves the homeland security budget flat
the one thing we should be devoting more
resources to
is the one item he decided to leave out
but the fawning fake newsers in the
press they continue to play defense for
joe
at every turn they continue to act as an
arm of the democrat party
instead of focusing on biden's failures
and his total
complete inability to lead don't believe
me
look at this embarrassing fiasco this
week
when they asked sleepy about his ice
cream take a look
mr president chocolate chocolate chip
oh to yeah
who are prepared to block the january
6th mission
nice work fellas hard hitting hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else